>> Tucker: SO IF YOU ARE GOING
TO HAVE A COUNTRY THE SIZE OF A
COMPETENT, AND WE DO, YOU NEED
CONSISTENT AND RELIABLE AIR
TRAVEL.
IT'S NOT A LUXURY, IT'S A
NECESSITY.
THE ECONOMY DEPENDS ON IT.
UNDER THIS ADMINISTRATION, THE
NETWORK, THE VERY DELICATE AND
FUNCTIONAL NETWORK OF AIR TRAVEL
WE'VE BUILT UP OVER NEARLY 100
YEARS, IS FALLING APART.
THEY JUST ANNOUNCED THEY HAVE A
MAJOR PILOT SHORTAGE, THEY ARE
PLANNING TO DROP SERVICE IN 29
DIFFERENT CITIES BUT SOUTHWEST
ALSO IS SLASHING FLIGHTS IN
APRIL AND MAY BECAUSE OF
STAFFING PROBLEMS.
IT'S NOT JUST A STAFFING.
THE VAX MANDATES DIDN'T HELP AT
ALL.
ACCORDING TO ONE AVIATION
CONSULTING FIRM, WE ARE GOING TO
BE SURE 21,000 PILOTS BY THE END
OF THIS YEAR.
WITHIN SIX WILL BE SHORT BY
NEARLY 60,000 PILOTS BEAR WE
HAVE A CHANCE PETITION
DEPARTMENT THAT WORKS PRETTY
MUCH FULL-TIME IN ELIMINATING
RACIST ROADS AND OTHER EQUITY
AGENDAS.
ARE THEY DOING ANYTHING ABOUT
THIS PROBLEM?
JASON RANTZ JOINS US TONIGHT.
HEY, JASON.
>> HEY, TUCKER.
YOU ARE RIGHT, THE AIRLINE
INDUSTRY IS CRUMBLING AND
PETE BUTTIGIEG IS LECTURING US
ABOUT RACIST HIGHWAYS WHICH
MAKES SENSE IF YOU DON'T WANT TO
FLY MUCH WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT
HE'S GETTING.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF LIGHTS ARE
BEING CANCELED, THOUSANDS A WEEK
BEING DELAYED MAKING TRAVEL
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT ESPECIALLY
IN SOME OF THE SMALLER CITIES
THAT YOU THINK PETE BUTTIGIEG
WOULD PAY ATTENTION TO.
GOOD LUCK FLYING FROM NORTH
TEXAS TO LOUISVILLE ON SOUTHWEST
AIRLINES.
SOME FLIGHTS WERE JUST CUT.
AMERICAN AIRLINES/70% OF ITS
SCHEDULE THIS MUCH.
ALASKA'S 5%.
U.S. CUTTING 21,000 FLIGHTS DUE
TO A STAFFING SHORTAGE FROM THE
COVID VACCINE MANDATE, ONE THAT
WAS MADE WORSE AS A RESULT.
AIRLINES WERE DOWNPLAYING ALL
THE TERMINATION.
LIBERAL REPORTERS NEVER DID MUCH
DIGGING.
BUT AS OF JANUARY, THERE WERE
31,000 FEWER FULL-TIME AIRLINE
WORKERS THEN BEFORE COVID.
AND WHILE WE WERE TOLD PRETTY
MUCH EVERYONE WAS COMPLIANT,
TURNS OUT PEOPLE WERE ALSO
QUITTING OR RETIRING EARLY.
GOT SO BAD THAT JETBLUE IS
BASICALLY BEGGING THE FLIGHT
ATTENDANTS TO TAKE ON OPEN
SHARES.
ALASKA AIRLINES IS PAYING DOUBLE
TO TAKE ON EXTRA WORK.
IT'S THE NUMBER OF RETIRING
PILOTS IS THE MOST ALARMING.
NO FLIGHTS MEANS -- CUT FLIGHTS
FROM PORTLAND TO DENVER, UNITED
CUT FROM DOLE'S
TO ALL LOCATIONS.
THEY ARE LOOKING TO CUT ROUTES
THAT CONNECTS TO SMALLER HUBS.
THEY ARE NOT PROFITABLE BECAUSE
A CUSTOMER BASE IS TOO SMALL.
THE DEPARTMENT OF DANCE AND
SUBSIDIZES IT.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS SERVICE
IMPACTS AND THREATS OF LOSING
FLIGHTS, PLAYABLE COLORADO,
MASON CITY COLORADO.
ALL THE DOJ HAS DONE IS TELL
THAT YOU CANNOT DO THESE ROUTES
UNTIL THEY FIND ANOTHER CARRIER
TO PICK UP THESE LIGHTS.
SKYWEST ONLY WANTS OUT OF THE
OTHER SHORTAGES AIRLINES ARE
HAVING.
DESPERATE FOR PILOTS, PAYING
MORE, EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS,
HIRING PILOTS FROM AUSTRALIA,
THIS IS EXPENSIVE AND IT'S
HAPPENING AT A TIME WHERE WE ARE
SEEING A PRICE SURGE FOR GAS.
>> Tucker: UNBELIEVABLE.
THE VAX MANDATES DO THIS TO
AIRLINES, LET'S SEE THIS APPLIED
TO THE NAVY SEALs ON THE EVE
OF A WAR.
WHATEVER HAPPENS TO OUR MILITARY
QUESTION WE JASON RANTZ,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THINGS, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: THE RATINGS ON THE
OSCARS THE CLIENT EVERY YEAR
BECAUSE WATCHING PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT THEMSELVES IS NOT
INTERESTING SO THIS YEAR THEY
HAD A BRAND-NEW IDEA.
LET'S DO SOMETHING SO DEGRADED
AND VIOLENT AND EVERYONE WILL
TALK ABOUT US.
WE ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT